ملف اخر الان هو الملف النووي الايرانيه
حيث اعرب المدير العام لوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رفايل جروس عربه عن امله في
الاستئناف الحوار مع ايران على اسس وصفها
بالجاده من شانها تقديم واجوبه عن مدى
التزام ايران بتعهداتها النوويه سي ان وقف
العمل بكاميرات المراقبه في المنشات
النوويه الايرانيه زاد نقاط الاموض بشان
بعض الانشطه الايرانيه
لن اوقف جهودي وسعي لجعل ايران تتعاون
معنا وتفهموا ان لديها التزامات طبعا
ايران دوله ذات سياده ولا يمكنني اجبارها
على ذلك ولكن لدي هدف واحترام الالتزامات
التي ينص عليها القانون الدولي وفي بعض
النقاط الفنيات الدقيقه التي يجب على
ايران توضيحها نحاول تبسيط الامور للحصول
على اجوبه ولحث ايران على التعاون اعتقد
انه من مصلحتهم ان يعملوا معنا وكما قررت
عده مرات ليس للوكاله اي اجنده سياسيه نحن
نقوم بعملناهم مطالبون بالتعاون وهذه اسوس
النشاط النووي السلمي في العالم
في المقابل حضره وزير الخارجيه الايراني
حسين الامير عبد الله هيان من عواقب اي
اجراءات الامريكيه واوروبيه غير بناءه في
مجلس محافظي وكاله الطاقه الذريه وكان
رئيس هيئه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه محمد
اسلامي قد قال ان بلاده سترفض اي قرار
يصدر ضدها من قبل مجلس محافظ الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
وستعتبره دون قيمه واضاف ان المسود
المطروحه ضد طهران تظهر ان الاطراف
المقابله ليس لديها او لديها حسن
نيه على حد تعبيره
السياسات
الضغوط القصوى وتوجيه الاتهامات المسوده
المطروحه في مجلس محافظ الوكاله تاتي في
هذا الاطار ومليئه بالنقاط غير الحقيقيه
والخاطئه اي قرار يصدر ضدنا لا قيمه له
ومرفوض تماما في الوقت الراهن لا يوجد
برنامج لزياره وفد من الوكاله الى طهران
قمنا بالرد على الاتهامات والنقاط العالقه
والمسوده المطروحه ضدنا بهذا المستوى
والشكل تظهر عدم وجود حسن نيه لدى الاطراف
المقابله
ان انتاج ايران من اليورانيوم عالي
للتخصيب وبالنسبه تصل الى 60% لا يمكن ان
تكون له اغراض سلبيه وكانت اعماله مجلس
محافظ الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه التدريبيه
قد انطلقت في العاصمه
النمساويه وتستمر ثلاثه ايام ومن المتوقع
يبحث المجلس ضمن اعماله مدى التزام ايران
بتعاهداتها نوويه وتعاونها مع الوكاله
وقالت مصادر مصادر دبلوماسيه ان المجلس
سيناقش مشروع قرار يدينه ما وصفته بعدم
تعاون ايران مع الوكاله بشان وجود موده
نوويه في مواقع غير مصرح عنها